- How are you doing?
- Good, doing well.
- Yeah? Okay.
So wait, we were talking
about getting away with stuff.
Were you the kid that ever
got away with anything,
like really good?
- Very much, I think I still am.
- Breaking rules?
- Yeah.
- I like it.
- I used to do this thing,
- For fun.
where if I was late, it only worked twice,
but when I was a kid and I was late,
I would call home and
when my mom picked up,
she would go, "Hello,"
and I'd go, "I got it."
- Oh, my-
- And she would think
I was home,
and I would just hang up.
- That's so clever.
- And then stay out for another
two hours, and come home.
She thought I was...
All she had to do was like
look down the hallway.
(audience laughing)
But, yeah. Yeah.
I was a brave-
- Now here's the thing-
- not smart child. (laughs)
- No, you are smart. That's very clever.
I feel like you deserved that.
- I've always wanted to put it in a movie.
It'll work.
- Yes.
- Oh, my gosh.
(Bobby laughs)
I'm totally gonna check my
kids' rooms when they're older.
Okay, so I wanna know,
'cause you've been on SNL,
I wanna know what are
your favorite characters
that you've ever gotten to play?
- Wow. I mean all of...
Anytime I was on camera at SNL,
15-year-old me was
extremely excited about it,
- Yeah.
- but I mean like...
Gosh, they all change.
- It is a certain energy.
I've been there, just
performing and stuff.
- Have you hosted?
- No, I don't know.
- You have to, you
would be a perfect host.
- It's such a commitment.
(audience cheering and applauding)
I was actually in New York
when Blake Shelton hosted
'cause-
- Ooh, I was there for that.
He was great.
- I know.
But it is a commitment.
Y'all work all week.
People don't get it.
It's not just Saturday night.
- No, it's a lot of work.
- It's like all week long.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
I feel like you are someone
that would excel at it though
- Oh, really?
- 'cause you're hilarious.
I feel like you would let them have fun,
and have a good time.
- Oh, I would definitely lean in
- Yeah.
I feel like you would be a great host.
I wanna see it.
- Okay.
(audience cheers and applauds)
(Bobby laughs)
- I love that.
Thank you. Thank you.
- Blake was great.
- Do you remember your very
first time that you were on SNL?
'Cause you said you were
15-year-old, so it's freaking out.
So, what was like your
first, do you remember?
- Yeah, I totally remember.
It was like Space Camp.
- Aw.
- It was nuts.
I mean, the first episode
was the only one I enjoyed
because I was like,
(Kelly laughs)
"I'm here. I can't believe it."
And then there was a job after that.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah, no.
I definitely, in between two scenes
in my first episode, ran
full speed across the studio
and changed really fast
'cause we're on live TV,
and then I had like a minute and a half.
And I was just standing-
- But you think
a quick change-
- there going like,
"Yeah, yeah. I guess I'm
very excited to be here."
(both laughing)
- Oh, my God.
You had your pocket protector on.
- Yeah, I was very...
(Kelly laughs)
My old SNL book.
(both laughing)
- Love it.
So wait, do you remember
your first time performing
in front of a crowd?
Were you nervous or did you feel at home?
- I don't think I was nervous,
and maybe that's why I'm here now.
- Me neither.
- I think I'm like Santa Claus
when I was a kid in school,
- Yeah.
like in third grade and
remember being like, yeah.
- The kid never gets to play Santa Claus.
That's awesome.
- Yeah, I wasn't even chubby then,
like I am now.
- No, I just mean
(audience laughing)
like most kids have to be
like elves or something.
You got to be the big man.
- That's awesome.
- I got to be Santa.
Yeah. I was like the
only one who said yes,
and I had a beard (Kelly
laughs) when I was four.
(Bobby laughs)
- So, it fit.
I love it.
- Yeah.
And then every year, for nine
years at SNL, it was like,
"It's December, you gotta put on
a Santa Claus costume five times
a week for the next month."
- Oh, my God.
(Bobby laughs)
That's awesome, though.
Wait, I love that your first
time wasn't scary, though.
A lot of times when performers
would say they were terrified
and I was like, that's
why I feel like I'm here.
I enjoyed it.
Like my first time was on stage.
It kind of felt like home away from home.
- Yeah. I remember like,
I was like the big finish at the end,
was putting on this Santa Claus jacket,
and it was inside out, and they did it,
they handed it to me wrong.
- Oh.
- And I remember making
some joke about it,
and then putting it on,
and it got a big laugh-
- And then a star was born.
- Being like,
"Well, that's how it's done, people."
- Yeah. (laughs)
Like, at the age of three.
- Already clever and funny.
(Bobby laughs)
(audience applauding)
I love it.
- So, congrats on season
two of "Mr. Mayor".
- Thanks. Thank you.
- That's amazing.
- For people that haven't seen it yet,
what is the show kind of about?
Who's your character?
- I play Jayden Kwapis on "Mr. Mayor".
It's a show about, Ted
Danson plays the mayor of LA,
Mayor Bremer.
Thanks.
And he's kind of just
trying to prove to himself
that he could still do
it and to his daughter.
And maybe he shouldn't
be, or maybe he should.
We'll see.
(Bobby laughs)
- I love that, the suspense.
You also have a podcast, and
it's "Celebrity Sightings",
right?
- Yeah.
So, what is your coolest
celebrity sighting or weirdest?
I'll take any.
- Oh, wow.
I do have a podcast
called "Celebrity Sighting
with Jonathan Biting".
I play a character, a
hundred-year-old man.
That's him.
(Kelly laughs)
I play a hundred-year-old man
named Jonathan Biting, who hides in bushes
and takes pictures of celebrities.
(both laughing)
My weirdest celebrity encounter,
gosh, I wish I had a better one,
like just regularly on the street.
I did, I ran into Anthony Daniels,
the guy who plays C-3PO,
- Yeah.
- on the street.
And I recognized him, and
I think he was shocked
that I recognized him out of costume,
I think.
- Yeah.
- But he was walking
like C-3PO.
(audience laughing)
He was.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
I think-
- "Maybe they'll know who I am."
(everyone laughing)
- I think, by far, the weirdest
one was definitely at SNL.
I was walking down the
hallway in a moose costume
with a moose head.
- As you do.
And Sarah Palin walked by me.
- Yeah.
- I never met her before.
Never said a word to her.
Her first words to me, as she walked by,
she never looked at me,
she just went,
(imitates gun cocking)
"Moose!"
- Oh, my God.
(audience laughing)
(Kelly and audience laughing)
That's actually fantastic.
Wait.
- Super weird.
(Bobby laughs)
She was ready to go hunting.
- Yeah.
She had it ready.
- Oh, my God.
- It feel like not her first
moose that she's encountered.
(Kelly and audience laughing)
- Not in Alaska. No.
- No, no, definitely inside "30 Rock".
- Huh?
(both laughing)